hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
welcome to 2014 some fun facts about
this last year 2013 I uploaded 102
videos and those videos were watched
about 50 million times
also this begins my sixth year of making
tech videos which means I've spent
somewhere around a third of my life
talking tech to a camera basically but
what better year to hit a stride than
2014
beginning with CES now if you don't
already know this International Consumer
Electronics Show happens in Las Vegas
every year in the beginning and that's
where thousands and thousands of
companies will come and show up and show
off their latest tech and hundreds of
thousands of more people will come to
check out that new tech including a lot
of us youtubers so I will be there but
let's face it I'm one person I can't
possibly cover all of CES that's just
way too much some blogs will do that
really well they have a team of people
and some YouTube channels will be
uploading basically a flood of coverage
in an attempt to cover everything but my
CES game at least here on the mkbhd
channel will be a little bit different
I'm going to be on the lookout for the
absolute best of the best of what that
CES gonna go for a sort of a highlight
reel type of approach and figure out
what exactly is worth seeing but I'm
still going to need a little bit of your
help for this I'm basically going to ask
for you guys to get at me on Twitter at
mkbhd during a show next week so you can
show me and tweet at me things that you
want to see on video maybe you saw
something on a blog that looked really
cool you want to see a video of it let
me know I will be looking at Twitter all
week and also if you see me in person at
the show because I'm going to be there
and you might be there to get at me in
person and let me know so the easiest
way to keep track of my videos not only
in this week but for the whole year
basically is to turn on email
notifications it's actually pretty
simple to do and so you'll get a new
email for every upload but also there is
twitter so you can follow me on twitter
where i'll be sort of tweeting the stuff
that i don't necessarily make a video
about but that's still kind of cool
maybe a photo of it or some background
information hopefully I get verified on
Twitter this year that'll be awesome
and there's also Google+ where actually
am verify
where I share not just my own videos but
some other stuff that I might find cool
so during the whole show at CES I'm
gonna be posting and sharing the cool
stuff that I find and hopefully doing
videos about the coolest of the cool
stuff that I find as far as CES
predictions go because that seems to be
something that people want to know I
would just expect a lot of pixels a lot
of pixels when I get back after the week
at CES the Mac Pro will be here the new
subtour project gets under way a lot of
people have been waiting for that and we
just basically get right back into the
Sony things for all of 2014 more
comparisons more high-quality reviews
more explained videos more collabs more
projects more pixels lots of lots of new
technology to explore and hopefully
you'll explore that with me this year so
thanks for watching and let's go ahead
and get into 2014 face